what is going on everybody welcome to
the best cooking show on earth I'm
pretty sure you've seen hot [ __ ] like
Martha Stewart cook you a steak but you
haven't seen a hot [ __ ] like me cook
you a steak so guess what we're making
today
steak and [ __ ] eggs now in
order to make my specific steak and eggs
of course you're gonna have to have a
dope piece of steak what I like to use
is short rib meat - the bone this right
here my friends is a sous-vide machine I
cook it in a water bath for about an
hour so it goes perfect medium-rare all
the way through before it touches this
hot app oh it stopped on its own BAM
here we have it now when you take it out
of the water bath itself the steaks
going to look a little gray it hasn't
touched oxygen in about an hour so and
the first thing that you're gonna do
before we go ahead and season these bad
boys is to make sure that they're bone
dry and the reason why you want to make
sure your steaks are bone-dry my friends
is because when you hit that [ __ ] right
into the pen you don't want it to steam
you want it to fry in the fat so we're
gonna tap those [ __ ] bone dry
wipe off this boom season generously big
piece of meat equals a lot of seasoning
if you under seasoned your [ __ ] you
might as well just slap yourself right
in the dick
you almost want it to be crusted with
this [ __ ] because I like my [ __ ] extra
peppery if it's not peppered well then
you're sitting and you just go right lid
in your [ __ ] face [ __ ] when you cook
your proteins and you want to brown it
you'll want to create a nice crust on it
and you only get that from high heat and
fat we sous-vide the steak this is
actually cooked to a perfect medium-rare
already it's already there
what we're
is just searing enough we're getting
that delicious bond that crustiness it's
going to be okay what you want to hear
sizzle
heat you see that my friends this is
what you want don't be scared of heat
you want the pan to be ripping hot this
is gonna go on for AB roughly about I
say a minute or so maybe even less just
to get that brown crust off' occation
flip oh [ __ ] you so you see the color
that's what we're looking for so this is
the dope part you're gonna get a lot of
butter knock that [ __ ] in there we're
gonna take those delicious garlic knobs
and we're gonna throw that in the butter
we're going to take the rosemary throw
that [ __ ] in there too you're going to
take that brown butter with the rosemary
on the inside and paste this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that is hot turn that [ __ ] off cuz I
don't need it anymore
remember the steak is really thick so
you're not gonna really cook it to the
center you're just basting it brown
butter fat rosemary will scent and
perfume this whole steak and trust me my
friends if this doesn't get you a little
[ __ ] or penis you're not doing it right
grab it with your tongs move it aside
boom let it rest take the rosemary put
it on top
oops while your steak is resting which
it technically doesn't need to because
it once again it's already been cooked
all the way through we [ __ ] I did the
wrong stove again we're gonna cook the
eggs for those of you out there who
don't know how to cook eggs I'm going to
teach you how to cook eggs if you don't
cook it the way I do you clearly don't
have friends or parents [ __ ] that's
actually pretty [ __ ] up egg number one
and it goes into the garbage can egg
number two and it goes into the
[ __ ] garbage can
egg number three keep me happy boom and
right here while the eggs in there what
you want to do is actually cook the eggs
slowly and the reason why I'm cooking a
slower my friends is because I'm looking
for my eggs to be almost
custard-like soft delicate beautiful I
wanted to speak to me it's gonna cook
slowly and this should take you roughly
about six or seven minutes depending I
know it's a long time for scrambled eggs
but if you want your scrambled eggs to
be good work it nice and slow be gentle
with it you want it to be nice and soft
and gooey much like the inside of a
girl's heart you were thinking I was
gonna say [ __ ] see that it's getting
there those curds are developing and I'm
trying to make sure we don't overcook
this so once it gets to this point
you're gonna take your fresh herbs
whatever you like we're actually using
curly parsley because it's one of my
favorite and this is the point where it
starts to dance and sing for you and
towards the end right here is when you
could add your seasoning I'm adding a
little bit of salt boom
turn off the heat there should be enough
residual heat for you to cook the rest
in the pan so once it gets to this point
here it's going to be perfectly fine
last piece BAM the bread now if you have
bread make sure that you also have a
serrated knife I actually forgot to
bring my damn knife but the cool thing
about this remember this guy right here
the butter and the meat fat guess what
we're gonna do with it got the wrong one
we are going to take wonderful pieces of
this bread do it at a bias maybe it's
not too smart that I have this plastic
bag next to the fire but who cares I'm
doing whatever the [ __ ] I want we are
going to put these little bad boys right
into that buttered fat and that starts
to go back to this steak now the steak
has rested up a perfect medium-rare I'm
just going to take this chunk off and
eat it myself
see that chef's choice well you can take
your steak pieces like so take that
beautiful soft scrambled egg with the
curly parsley on the side then of course
you're going to take those delicious
pieces of fried bread in the beef fat
and [ __ ] at the very end just remember
we had that brown butter and we're not
gonna leave that friend out and here you
have my friends we have the ultimate
steak and eggs
that's soft scramble with curly parsley
we have fat fry bread at of course we
had the brown butter that was drizzled
on top of that sous-vide short rib steak
everybody should be on the same color
profile if not believe I did my job
god damn it Vince you already [ __ ] up
welcome everybody to the bet oh [ __ ]
let's do that again [ __ ] okay and
that's what you want to hear sizzle
heat fire where the [ __ ] are the tongs
[Music]
but this is the part that takes the
longest you got to be gentle with the
[ __ ]
I actually learned how to scramble eggs
from what's-her-name Julia Child's Julia
Child's was one of my childhood heroes I
wanted to be just like her six foot one
and a woman the hell did I just say cool
ha ha let's not go next